I turned to my right and I see somebody
who the last time he was here he was an
undrafted player out of the you getting
set to be the 29th overall pick of the
2017 draft out of the Cleveland Browns
good to see you David and chuckles good
to see you too rich how are you I'm good
how are you last time you were here on
this show I don't believe you had that
watch on either serious piece of bling
though you're appreciated that is your
left that is your arm right there's an
arm I'm looking at correct you know that
looks like Marla looks like you know
what would you say my pinky great to see
you man
great this is great to see you let's get
into this thing right now how exciting
is it in your in your neck of the woods
very exciting obviously you know there's
a lot of talk you know go on with the
Browns you know so we're really excited
for this year to start okay
and is that a good thing that there's a
lot of talk surrounding the Browns I
mean frankly it doesn't really matter
you know because at the end of day it's
it's football and we have to work on
what we got to do to you know go all the
way you know so talk here talk there it
doesn't really matter what are you
working on I mean it is obviously we're
not touching the offense based on what
we saw over the last few weeks or last
year right same thing same thing how so
I mean same type of offense yeah similar
similar similar so now that Freddie
kitchens is the HC as opposed to the OSI
it's it's a different playbook well
initially you know Freddie was the the
running backs coach you know when he was
there yes and when he left became the
OSI so you know it's similar but you
know there's different stuff there's a
new wrinkle or two a little bit okay
what's it like having a Odell around
great gray honestly with him Jarvis and
I've said earlier Jarvis Calloway
Higgins Duke Kareem chav I can go on for
days you know we have a we have a great
offense and I'm here talking with the
defense you know defense were SEC - so
we're really excited for this year why I
remember before he left to be the
general manager of the Raiders and to
combines ago mike Mayock was sitting
next to me saying the defense is ready
to go it's the offense that needs to
come together and get some some cohesion
and you know the the Browns draft Baker
and we saw what happened once
got into the game and to me this is all
it's all on you guys now to execute is
that the way you view it as well well
honestly um being up her some athlete
it's always on us to execute you know
and uh obviously my first year we
haven't really done that too well so
this past year it was a big jump from my
first year and this the upcoming year
we're looking to you know play
everything together okay what's your
favorite Baker story
give me a favor I'd say the Raiders game
he scrambles out and he got hit pretty
hard and jumped up and he was fired up
and honestly like I was I was just so
impressed you know he has he has great
he's very competitive and and he has
great courage so give me a little more
context so um he you know hikes the ball
he's grant he's Lee no running around
that's at the pocket and stuff and uh
start scrambling and runs for maybe I'd
say don't quote me on this but maybe
like 25 30 yards and um a DB or whatever
hit him pretty hard
like pretty hard and he jumped up said
whoa you know like he's you know fired
up and everything and I was just like
that I got me hyped you know like at
that moment because I just you know saw
like the intensity and the energy so it
was really exciting that's the game guys
screw it on about the spot towards ya
you know it happens but you know that's
not can see I can see I can see no no no
you know I'll just say those words you
don't have to you know take the high
road and then give me the know it's it
sucks you know what whatever happened
but at the end of day you can't change
it so no I know that I so did he did he
give voice David and Joker here on the
show did he give voice to the way the
locker room felt about Hugh Jackson when
he didn't go in for the hug and gave him
a handshake and the Heisman and then
when asked about it just spoke about it
in plain language that you've rarely
hear from a quarterback did he give
what's he giving voice to what many
people in the locker room thought David
well obviously we weren't happy with
what Hugh said about us after he left
you know
you know it is what it is and and Baker
didn't appreciate that so we know we
came together after he left and and you
know took upon ourselves to work the
extra you know work extra hard to finish
the year off strong so well cuz he got a
lot of him Baker got a lot of heat for
saying that and I saw it I'm like I
think he's just given voice to a people
in the locker room or saying and that
was a moment that again obviously you
want to build around something positive
I totally understand that and that's
wins and that's excitement and this may
come across as something negative the
way that Baker had talked about it so
openly but it's still something that we
can rally aright I mean hmm yeah I
respect him a hundred percent you know
you know Baker has a voice as we all do
and he didn't appreciate what happened
so you know it's it's not like we're
robots you know we have we you know he
we we felt in a way to suspect it so
that is what it is Browns tight end
David and Joe ku here on the Rich Eisen
show and I love Odell I just think he is
somebody that is occasionally
misunderstood and occasionally totally
understood and I can't wait to see what
he balls out like I'm wondering what
your first blush reaction to just again
like him being part of the team yeah
so I found out that he got traded it's
us when I was here in Los Angeles a few
months ago yes and I was just so excited
you know I've known him before he got
traded and he has a tremendous work
ethic you know he's a great teammate you
know I just being with him for these
like past you know few weeks that he was
here in Cleveland rather you know it's
just great excitement great energy you
know he I truly feel that he's a great
teammate well you excited you come from
the you and obviously they're LSU yeah
you know I see that right there I know I
know so you know what it's about being
around a passionate fan base did you
notice last year when the wind started
to happen what was going on in the
stands they're talking about in
Cleveland yes sir oh yeah I mean yeah of
course you know it was just like a chain
you know when we first won our first
game well my first game being at a
Cleveland Brown against the Jets last
year it was just like a great feeling
that you don't want to lose you know you
wonder you want to keep winning you want
to keep working that much harder to get
those wins and they're very important
for us yeah but just to see what the
fans I mean yeah big big night for
Cleveland what about you what is your
what are your goals what walk me through
honestly speaking um I didn't I don't
really put numbers into my goals I just
feel like if I gave everything I could
you know to the game you know just
worked my hardest I feel like I'll feel
accomplished so so you know that being
said I want 20 touchdowns this year but
yeah like I just feel for me I just
knowing that I just gave all of it like
all I got is the will make me feel
accomplished so mm-hmm and know what's
what else is going on and your in your
life what else is happy I already work
how about that let's start with yeah so
I was supposed to fly to Nigeria this
past offseason to donate 400 soccer
cleats 100 soccer balls do you know -
you know back to my home homeland
you know the motherland but I had a
scope on my knee and it kind of started
from doing that so this next offseason
I'm planning on doing that and I also
have a kid's camp July 13th and back in
my hometown in Cedar Grove New Jersey
Cedar Grove yeah so we're really excited
about that it's supposed to be a big
event I believe I'm host I'm taking over
the NFL's Instagram - mm-hmm so yeah
it's gonna be fun and great for the kids
how many tickets you got to get when
you're playing the Jets in New Jersey I
have a bunch of family and friends that
are very eager to go I'm sure I'm sure
they gonna Monday night or - I believe
so that's a big time I mean we're
excited for that I bet so I would
prepare yourself for that I mean
I have a bunch of friends that already
you know order their tickets I believe
already so yeah we're excited for that I
have some family coming as well it's
gonna be a fun night what exit is Cedar
Grove I believe you asked me this like
four years ago or three years ago and I
probably still can't tell you honestly
think you got it wrong last 45 to go to
280 280 to Cedar Grove it's right there
Livingston's right next you to grow no I
don't think that says Mike Montclair
like Montclair Verona 140 it would go up
higher it's called the Internet right in
front it's mighty nice Mike you're over
- I love this by the way I would love to
have a who knows Jersey better off with
David and joko Cleveland is right you
can take the Parkway you can get off at
280 which is 145 and then you go to the
police academy in Cedar Grove County
police Academy's there at some point did
you feel unsafe as a very small child
when Mike Dell 2fo is on the beat
rapping his police car around a tree if
I'm not mistaken you can get off highway
3 3 to 46 and go south Cedar Grove yeah
you wind up with you again from Jersey
how did that happen Shakti connection
you get you get offered and then you
know I got recruited by um by Marc
D'Onofrio and an al golden okay
and I last-minute Rose Miami all right
I'm gonna put you on the spot however
let you go cuz your man who I think can
handle your broad shoulders I can handle
it
greatest wide receiver in the history of
the you
I can pick one start bench cut greatest
wide receiver in the history of the you
oh Michael Irvin Reggie Wayne Andre
Johnson David and Jo ku understand you
left off Santana Moss and Devin Hester
Michael Allen herds Reggie Wayne because
I want to create a huge stink Andre
Johnson yes those are the three best who
always always in on NFL gameday morning
just so you understand I might give you
some cover I always called Andre Johnson
the greatest receiver in the history of
the you as I was looking directly at
Michael Irvin saying those words David
and Joker can you start bench cut okay
now before I say this all three
receivers are exceptional receivers I
would go I'm gonna start Michael Irvin
just because you know his intensity you
know like it's like his the what he
brings to the game is just superb and
he's probably watching
I would bench Andre because I know
sooner or later who need him in the game
to make some crazy plays and
unfortunately Reggie here my dog but I'd
cut Reggie just because you gave me this
hard hard question this morning this is
fun
no this is fun oh we could do this for
several position
okay right greatest Titan in the history
of the you Jeremy Shockey Greg Olson
David and Joe ku start bench cut well no
question I definitely started David a
joke oh I mean he first off is just
probably one of the most handsomest you
know tight ends we got by the way we're
giving you we're giving you like that
Family Feud these are like the best of
the best in my opinion when it comes to
tight ends yeah I love having you on
David but there's more than every I
guess every two years no you got drafted
in 2017 I think you were 20 when you
came on right you're 20 to you about to
be 23 correct you about to be 23 medical
23 yes sir mm-hmm
very up yeah and we'll have you on
whenever whenever you want I always
enjoy Jets I've been rooting for you as
you know since before you got drafted
thank you miss oh it's great to see you
here and now I have but one question
because I asked the question earlier and
you'd answer what was your latest
40-yard dash time okay and do we have a
video for this to watch boom you got it
well actually all you need to do is just
look at the mug and see me standing
still on the mug while trying to run it
it's as close to the actual thing for
six oh six flat was a six five or six
classic six five and I will say this on
my third try with a partially torn
growing muscle that's impressive do not
mess it up the core and went for it
that's also just again just look at the
mug and that's what it looks like love
it
thanks for coming on what was your 40
time something right combine I didn't do
too high bring like a 4 6 and then pro
to ever enough for for 8 so yeah but you
know what the you it's a it's a it's a
it's a quicker trigger finger yeah you
know everything's faster in Florida
that's right all right greatest
defensive lineman of all time SAP no I'm
just kidding the rock by the way they
played next to each other they groomed
together at the early yeah thanks for
coming on my pleasure David and Joe coup
up tight end right here on the rich oz
and sure we come back the latest would
bomb apparently in the NBA free agent
front and Chris Mannix a Sports
Illustrated no doubt to react to that
that's how we're rolling here don't you
dare move here on the Rich Eisen show
for more of the Rich Eisen show tune -
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV for free
on BR live or download the Rich Eisen
show app